parents across the country are fighting
back against critical race theory
loudoun county virginia becoming one of
the epicenters of this battle with
moms and dads speaking out at school
board meetings this week
but the white house is brushing aside
their concerns
i don't think we would think we believe
that uh educating uh
the youth and next then leaders of the
future leaders of the country on
systemic racism is
indoctrination that's actually
responsible
so martha if it's not indoctrination why
is there
so much disagreement about this and why
is there so much
passionate pushback from parents of all
races
you know it all stems from the 1619
project which started in the new york
times which
put out a theory that 1619 is the actual
foundation and origination of the united
states of america and that it should not
be looked at
as 1776 and a lot of this uh has made
its way to the white house in terms of
grants and the money that they would
give to different
educational um institutions across the
country they'd be more favored if they
are teaching this so people have started
to figure out what is
in these documents i actually spent part
of today looking at curriculums
that involve critical race theory which
include the ideas
that if you are white and you
think or say that you are not racist
it essentially signifies that you are
racist you are just not
aware of it and you know we look at what
happened to sharon osborne right and
that was the classic dressing down that
she got she said i'm not a racist i've
never been a racist
uh and they said well it's just that you
don't realize that you are so the more
the more that people start to understand
this and it doesn't matter if they're
black or white as we have seen in these
school board meetings uh they start to
intrinsically know that there is
actually something wrong with this
and that they don't want the future
leadership of the country
to be taught that we are a racist
country
so that's what they're teaching them
jesse and it amounts to propaganda
the problem is in big cities like new
york and los angeles and d.c
high schoolers are well below grade
level in terms of math and english
proficiency
so why not teach them actual
things that they they need to learn in
school
like how to read and how to do basic
math
yeah i'm all for that kennedy and if you
look at what critical race theory is
it tells you that white people are bad
and that white people are oppressing
black people now juan's black juan is
not oppressed
anyone that wears cufflinks is not
oppressed and every time i see
juan show pictures of his family
everyone looks beautiful like they're
having the time of their lives
i looked at some of these details too in
shipley school outside of philly nice
prep school very pricey
they're actually telling parents that
they don't want the parents to tell
their kids
you have beautiful blue eyes because
blue
eyes raises to a standard of white
european beauty
and marginalizes brown-eyed people now
you know how i feel about this i don't
think schools should be giving homework
to parents at all we have enough on our
plate
in buffalo buffalo is teaching kids that
if you are white you are just
participating in systemic racism
that's like saying all people are that
are white
are racist when we all know the real
problem in buffalo
are people being bills fans in oregon
they are teaching you that math is
racist
ridiculous math is just boring in
washington d.c
they're telling you that the phrase hard
work is the key to success
is a form of white oppression you ask
any black athlete black entrepreneur
black artist they will tell you the key
to success is hard work
i think 100 so to me it sounds like
this critical race theory is a scheme
for white
liberals to subvert black achievement
and that's what the real oppression is
about black parents want their
kids to read the classics to learn math
and absorb american history so they can
get into college and then once you're in
college
you can learn about how everybody's
racist but you got to get into college
first
you do and with such horrible standards
especially after the pandemic one
what's surprising to me and i would
never tell you
one about your experience and how
race has affected your worldview and
your life
and your feelings but i also don't want
to hear that from someone else i don't
want to hear from someone that
my immutable characteristics or my
children's immutable characteristics
somehow make them bad people
i think that's incredibly unfair and you
know we've all been raised that
equality is the ultimate goal but now
that's been
replaced with equity and you know
this as the new york post pointed out is
a form of marxism your thoughts
wow it's hard to know where to start
kennedy but
i'll start here i think talking about
race makes
lots of people uncomfortable i think
some people think it invites
charges of guilt embarrassment there's
resentment
there's disagreement all of that's there
but i don't think that healing
on what is a major problem in american
society i don't think healing can begin
unless we have the conversation
and if all of you are saying that you
know school children are such snowflakes
you can't tell them about american
history you can't tell them about
slavery
you can't tell them about the rise of
the clan you can't tell them about
black people being lynched that's it
that's
sorry but you still have hang on a
second martha because that's not true we
still have states in this country
where they ban textbooks that talk about
slavery is the cause for the civil war
where they don't want to hear
about ongoing racism in this society
they say oh
you know what that's indoctrination
that's not indoctrination
that's history that's having young
people deal honestly
with who we are as americans but instead
what you get is especially from
conservative politicians
they say oh no we want our kids to be
proud patriots and proud of america
yeah well they can be proud i'm a very
proud american
but i'm also very aware of some of our
defects especially in terms of the
original sin
of racism and slavery
i understand that but don't tell me i'm
a bad person because
i'm white when my mom came over on a
boat uh with
with one suitcase for five people and
was discriminated against
actively uh when she got to these united
states but you know what she got uh two
advanced degrees
and became an engineer and is completely
self-made because of the american
experience and i'm proud of her
uh so anyway you should be she's great
she's incredible
go ahead will you know i'll just say
this i'm not afraid of the conversation
juan
i'm open to the conversation in fact i
welcome the conversation but i don't
think healing can be done until we look
at each other as individuals
as individuals who are judged upon their
merit their character their soul who
they are
as individuals this curriculum asks us
to double down on our shallow
characteristics who we are on our skin
color level
jesse laid out several things it teaches
this curriculum teaches that
individualism itself
is a sign of white supremacy i have a
problem with that if the
current teaching is that we will not
look at each other's individuals but do
we have to look at each other as tribes
i consider that poison worse than poison
i consider that racism and i'm welcoming
that conversation
anytime someone wants to have it all
right and we will continue that
conversation
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis
you will not get it anywhere else